a
こんにちははじめ社長ですそういう下段の最近の動画とか何か良い塩砂糖がにも買って
あげてるんですけども肇社長のキングどうなっちゃってるんだ問題
たまに言われますね twitter とかでつべと結構話す事は言われるんですけど
も実はですね鍛えせるのお腹だけじゃなくて最近ちょっと全身期待てるんですよで
ちょっと前までの僕の交あたっていうかな
消防みたいなので燃やせっていうのがあったんですけども
多分もうもう使われることはダイエットでもしない限りはないかなと思うからちょっと
最近実は筋トレを頑張っております肇社長です自粛中の趣味の一環ですと言われて
ちょっと前の私こんな感じでございます
腕とかも細いしても6でも骨が見えてたりお腹はなんか細い1にはちょっとね肉が乗っ
てきたりしてたっていう状態だったんですけどもまぁ今年
に入ってから腹筋を鍛え自粛期間になって wedding ジムを作って本格的に胸
腕買った全体的に期待初めて私に今の体
こんな感じになっております
が2月に期待でいる方からすると全然そんなことないんですけども以前の僕と比較して
みてくださいもう誰だってくれた分身力がアップしてると思うよ胸もついたしある程度
腕とめっちゃくちゃ最近あの
やってるんでそれにかなりついた方かなと思いますね
それこれ短期間なんですよ本音本当に多分し茎が始まってくらいでせっせと筋トレして
みたんですけども目がどんな特性
落としてなくて1日30分ちょいくらいなんか一生懸命なんか健介とかねチントレし
てる後輩と彼に教えてもらいながらなんとなきゃっていう筋トレメニューなんですけど
もこれを続けてたらなんかこんな感じになったってトレーニングを一重を紹介だけして
おきます
どうぞ結果持っています
ああああああ
[拍手]
[音楽]
ああああああ
voodoo
あ
何か言われねーさんとしたら何か良いって色々あるんで
まず後れていますいや腕ですねバーベルを持ち上げるだけで作って切った姉御廟をかけ
てあげて国受けて避けるの
返せるじゃないんですずう無理だって思ったその先+に1回でやめましょう
いますあ
[音楽]
猫横から8
腕に力が入っていうか分かるんで
[音楽]
神ですよく飲みながらだってああすげえ
音響きたジェンナーというのを実感したから行き
やってます
1持って
とぅっ
ん
[音楽]
here are ヌーサティ無理あげて
群れに競技を[ __ ]されますちょっと情けない姿になると思うけど許してください
保険いつもいません
a
hey
ねぇ
さあは暗かったら勝てるねっ
シェイ
ふたえん
go うーん
6はぁっ
はい
せーじへい
埋めちゃうん
あっはぁ
me
って言うねぇ
[音楽]
2宝石あーげーなー
家のほかへ
yeah 2
pane
ああああああ
ええええええ
でああ1
ああああああ
んだよ
ヒーター1回会えるこの胸のホラー jump pump されるんですよってあの
応じた60上がらないんですよ
で野球で上がってないよくれる胸してでもその
こそしないぐらいの重さってですかオス海外数上げてここを鍛えるのがいいって
コーチが言ってましたはいみなさん見て分かった通りあの私に無理が弱いんだよねはら
ばっかり期待でぬぐって胸とか片腕がないからちょっと色んなやマジでやってるわけで
ございます本当にが弱すぎる頑張っていく階でございます続いては雨が引くやつなん
ですけどこれでは肩と肩と胸が鍛えられるらしいのでやってますしかしそこで主君で
買っていこう
胸に
寄せ付ける完成やってます泣服のも早くしてもうすぐの一句やると目指すカクカクって
家に帰ってた
ジュンの人が言ってました背中で地区幹事買わなくっ追い越し0
[音楽]
ええええええ
ああああああ
はあああああ
ua a k i
はぁっ
ok 多いていけるよだよせーの
わー今度本当はだしてね
んだ
ええわー
[拍手]
やばいは胸はゼロになるかやると思っちゃう
断じて売りだ一切の力が愛はこれはいい
偶然 you the use a
はぁっ
ムーミン好き
ハッハー
次期4041本があっ
[音楽]
はあああああ
あまあはいという感じでございます何がトップ4なことと言うとなんかめちゃくちゃ
気合い入ってる時はもうめっちゃ9タンパク質摂ってますねプロテインとかプロテイン
バーとかささみとかサラダチキン
アーサーだけとりあえずご飯とか空にしてあとはもうなるべく賛成か別付4室あるもの
を抜いたりしてました最近はそうでもないんですけどもなんかもう死亡頑張りもなくて
これ時にこう大きくならないなって思って
なんかもう最近は逆にもう何か変えちょっと太ってみようかって思うくらいでござい
ますまーすっげー300回するだけだと本当に体のバランスが悪くなるもうお腹が出て
たんですよ
今をなんですけども晴れより9が出てるんですよこの上のはなむけに行く
これやばいなと思ってここでたらもうムートも期待ないとほんとバランス悪いなって
補正最近全身期待ていいか
木のこちらのほっ2じゃないですいい完全な細マッチョになればいいなとちょっと思っ
ておりますのでパチッと参考になるか分からないんですけどまぁ家にいる人ほんと
腕立てするだけでも全然胸筋が空くし腹筋とかもどこでもできると思うんだぜひ行って
みてはいかがでしょうか
このままだと僕年末どうなってしまうのでしょうか
the voodoo
[音楽]
ちょっと